hi and thank you for joining my name is
jennifer johnson i am the digital
marketing certificate associate trainer
with simply learn today i'm going to go
over email marketing foundations and the
introduction to email
now
let me say this
email right now has a bad rep
you know what let me just backtrack
i think the issue is that
there is a
large
number
of marketers
who don't have
the proper training on using these
strategies
and so um
a lot of people think that they're no
longer needed because of social media
networking but before i even begin on
telling you
introducing you to email marketing
let me just let you know that
all right wait a second
sorry
hi my name is jennifer johnson i am from
assembly learn i'm the digital marketing
certificates trainer today we will be
discussing email marketing foundations
the introduction to email
so email marketing is
another
misused concept and strategy that social
media provides because
a lot of people don't
use it effectively
they don't properly build their list
they don't probably send out emails they
don't properly connect with you
so what we're going to do today i'm
going to clear up all those
misconceptions that that you might have
about email and give you an introduction
and persuade you heavily on why you need
to start incorporating email marketing
strategy strategies in your digital
marketing plan
so email marketing
is a
powerful channel channel for you to
reach new customers retain customers and
maximize lifetime value let's break it
down buddy
so
in order to get a person in your email
database you have to provide them
something called a lead magnet
some people use a newsletter as an elite
magnet on their web page they're like
hey i want to sign up for my newsletter
and they just email them their
newsletter that's not effectively
utilizing your email database you
effectively use your email database by
creating something called a conversion
marketing funnel which starts with a
capture page in the lead page in the
email marketing system and they all work
hand in hand a capture page is a
one-page website that people can only do
one or two things enter their
information to get them to get the lead
magnet or exit
and the purpose of this is to capture
the person's information in exchange for
giving giving them something of value
something that they need a answer solve
to so for example um
a lead magnet would be
a a cheat sheet
or
a short training or um
a short guide you know just some
something quick and consumable that you
can get people in
and then you
um
immediately
they are entered into your email
marketing system
and stored there their contact
information is still there and so
once you they're stored there there
that's how you build your audience
that's how you build your customer base
and that's the way you start to do your
selling you don't do your selling
through um
sending people to your website you do
the selling through email
and
that's how you retain your customers
because you are you nurture your
customers and your database
you you nurture your lead database in
your customer database through sending
them
valuable content from your blog post
okay and that's called nurturing them
and you also send them specials and you
stay in contact with them once you have
a person's email you can
it's against um email regular
it's against um
the privacy act for you to spam
but you can provide and represent them
valuable information okay
and
that's by doing that you create lifetime
value with your customers because you
have built built up no like trust factor
with them so you know when you have new
products and services to come out people
like hey i need that and i like this
person let me buy it from them that's
what bigger brands do okay
bigger big brands they
capture their audience
they nurture them with producing
valuable content
and every time they come out with
something new they want to buy it
and we're going to teach you how to use
those strategies digitally through
simply learns digital marketing training
so make sure that you click the link you
click our subscribe button you click the
link below to get more information
email transformation
so what changed
oops
what changed an email see when people
first started using email um
actually for real when people really
first started using
the internet
and social media
they were
spamming
until marketers intervened
that's another story for a different day
and that's a story that i will share
with you in my class
so
people um people start their day by
checking their emails fifty percent of
emails are open on a mobile device which
is either a cell phone or tablet
and the preferred channels are um
it's a preferred channel seventy seven
percent of consumers prefer to receive
marketing messages through email versus
their social media sites
okay
email marketing email marketing
efficiency according to a study by the
direct marketing association a one
dollar investment can equal forty
dollars in revenue
that is a four hundred percent return on
event investments okay
so that means that email has the highest
return of
investment because
email marketing creates loyalty among
your customers as i mentioned once they
enter into your email database you they
they once they enter your email database
they're they start to go through
your conversion marketing funnel and
that's the process of you selling their
products your product to them as well as
you will be also sending them your blog
post
because sending your database your blog
post is a part of syndicating okay
it's a
email is a way to expand your customer
customer base and educate them about
your company yes you do that
but you're educating them by sending
them information from your blog post
okay so you have that information on
your blog
you send them a short email like hey you
want to learn more click here okay and i
click there they go to your website
that's how you create returning visitors
in a loyal customer base okay by
nurturing them by educating them by
doing that you're building intimacy and
you're creating the know like trust
factor among
your customers base
challenges with email spam spam spam bam
challenges with email
many
people use email to spam you
and they don't send you valuable
marketing messages
spam is wrong
say no to spam
especially if it's in a can
but no seriously say no to spam spam
means they just your spam means that you
are giving them unsolicited
um
[Music]
advertising about your product and we'll
talk more about that in my class so make
sure you subscribe to the channel click
the link below and you can join the
class okay
you send the valuable messages um when
you send spam you're not going to enter
the inbox but when you send valuable
information the chances of reaching a
person's inbox are um
higher but you know there are techniques
and tools
there are techniques that you have to
use
in your in your messages to make sure
that you are seen as relevant you're not
seen as excessive and relevant and
important that you're not spending
spamming people okay
and we will talk about those those
those techniques in the class
so
your email resurgency requires uh is
technology technological
email and
technology is mobile it's targeting and
it's personal
it's technology because it
you have to use a software
you have to use email marketing software
my favorite is mailchimp now i've been
to aweber i was at
gvo and i was at get response and the
reason mailchimp is the best and i'm not
soliciting for them i'm just sharing
with you the tool that i use the reason
that i like um mailchimp is because of
their um
the matrices inside
and what you're able to do and
how you're able to segment
your um customers
and
the only other
software that i've seen able to do that
is infusionsoft and infusionsoft is
expensive mailchimp is more affordable
for the um
for the entry-level business within the
entry level marketer
email is mobile as i mentioned 77 as i
mentioned in the previous slide 77
percent of people check their emails
through their phone i know i check my
emails through my phone all the time
like
having to check my email or my
computer's like really
but i do it because i have to
sometimes because my business emails on
my computer my my i have my gmail on my
cell phone
um
sorry sticking up mile and then this
targeting is targeting because
you have your customer base and the
people that are the people that are in
your email base are only people that are
interested in what you have to offer
it is the hottest lead list that you you
have and that's personal because you are
you're able to connect with them on a
personal level you can send as many
emails as you want today
i wouldn't i wouldn't advise sending
multiple emails a day but i'm just
saying that you can
you can't it's advised to do that if
you're you're in the middle of a launch
but just to connect with them now
the list
oh sorry
the list of email addresses
ha
in marketing as an internet marketer i'm
not sure how many of you are internet
marketers i'm pretty sure many many of
you are
um in a marketing
field
or eventually into marketing
but
your list your own list
so
your list of email addresses can be
people that are customers prospects
leads contacts newsletter subscribers
it's basically everybody that should
collect email addresses from your
website customers are people that have
bought from you so let me really break
it down to you um
in a format that makes sense to you
this right here
where you said newsletter subscribe this
is typically on your website and i'm
going to give you i'm going to give you
a secret that i just learned
this is bad this is bad do not use a
newsletter as a way for people to opt in
your
email list because nobody wants your
newsletter if you offer them something
of value like a lead magnet
you will have more people to subscribe
to you people that subscribe for your
lead magnet they are considered
prospects once they enter your database
they become a lead
and a lead is the same thing as a
contact
once they purchase from you they become
a customer
so
newsletters subscribers
um
moving forward
in the class i'll teach you about lead
magnets we're going to have to do you'll
do an assignment on creating your own
lead magnet
and you will take newsletter off
of your website immediately
because you have to stand out don't do
what everybody else is doing you have to
stand out and don't be boring nobody
wants your newsletter i'm just being
honest how many newsletters do you get
that you actually read like come on now
statistically speaking
most people don't open these letters and
it's boring just fyi sorry to brush your
bubble i'm just saying there are going
to be a lot of things that i'm going to
say is going to brush your bubble but
i'm only doing that because i want you
to succeed
i want you to be successful in your
digital marketing efforts and my job is
to educate you and tell you the truth
and to clarify any misconception that
you may have
because you will not leave my training
misinformed and confused and feeling
bamboozled
i want you to get the best education
possible which means that
i have to
clear up things that you thought were
right and i am sorry
if i hurt your feelings
let's move
forward your email server
so your email server act as a routing
and delivery agent for emails your email
can be your business server through your
internal
internal hosted a third-party hosting
through godaddy or rackspace or an email
service provider such as mailchimp so
let's just take let's take a look at um
i have i have two out of the three
i actually have the three i don't i no
longer do the third party hosting once i
learned about um
once i learned about having an email
service provider but i do have a um
business service so let me just take it
to my business or my business um
email first now let me say this
it's good for you to have two of two out
of the three
okay
you have this is my back office my
website is build your dream business
online this is my um email okay
this is a direct um this email
comes from the url is
to the url for my business it's
important for you to have because
you should have
it's important for you to have
because
you should be you should have a branded
email to your website
and let me also show you my mailchimp
mailchimp is my
email marketing system and is also
considered an autoresponder depending on
the field that you're in
so let me just share with you if you
don't if you don't have um
a email service server yet
mailchimp is free to start
okay
and you can log in for free and get and
see the back office without having to
purchase it um if you want upgrades such
as being able to automate automate your
emails you have to sign up and the um
it's very inexpensive you can get a 10 a
month
membership
and
let's just go over some of the features
real quick of
mailchimp
so um
let me
so let's look at let's look at it
you they have they
you're able to chart
your um
your list
and your campaigns and how many people
are opening up your emails
you are able to connect your
your e-commerce store shopify
magneto big commerce and woocommerce
it fits many brands you can
it has a wonderful design in the back
office
they have powerful tools for you to
explore your automation with different
um campaigns that you can use i'm going
to log in and let you see that this is
actually really really cool
you have different reports
and you have more you have hundreds and
hundreds of integrations okay
um what i love about it is that
is that you're able to do advanced
segmentation um
and that might segmenting your email
list may or may not be a topic
it's something that we will discuss
briefly
so let me just um
show you something real quick on my
mailchimp
i'm going to show you the automations
and automations mean that
there are other campaigns that you set
up for people different marketing
campaigns that you set up
for your products
so let me just show you this right real
quick you have e-commerce
automation non-profit education music
software list activity database custom
integration like there there are so many
awesome types of follow-ups that you can
do you have an abandoned car first
purchase
um follow-up
campaigns
non-profits you have supporter
onboarding membership renewal events
re-engagement as
different schools you have student
orientation course series student
re-engagement you have music downloads
record label information events events
follow-up
software pre-launch information white
page download product feature engagement
user onboarding
this activities when people just joining
your list
database you know you can enter you know
the information so you can you know make
it more more personalized
mothership is so cool
okay
um
let's just check out the education real
quick
this is
it's cool like it's it's really really
really cool
and when you are creating your list
you're able to do um
where is it this always confuses me
you can't you can't move your um
you're able to have many reports i'm i'm
just getting started um rebranding um
getting my business off the ground so i
don't have have this information yet but
it's available to me so getting back to
the slides um
in our presentation
you have to have your branded email
you have to have a branded email to your
url and you have to have a email service
provider third-party hosting through
your um you
through your hosting such as go daddy
your accessibility hostgator they do
offer email service but
it's weird and it's not nice and it's
not pretty and it's easy it's hard to
use and
like you don't need it you have you have
better options an email service provider
sends mass emails on your behalf and
handles all the legalities and sending
options and the handles and
list which is about why you need to use
something as like mailership or constant
contact constant contact is good if you
have it would be better
best if you have a have a
healthy advertising budget but if you
are a startup
you should use mailchimp because it's
inexpensive
batch and blast now there's different
same
your batch and blast our same email sent
to all um
all your lists so you can have for each
marketing campaign
each um
conversion funnel you have a diff
for each target market you have you will
have a different marketing campaign and
you can do a bastion blast to send a um
a
email to all of them so
um
generally speaking
you have
you have your different marketing
campaigns
for each for you for each product and
then when you're emailing your list
daily you're sending and syndicating
your blog you're doing a bashing blast
because you're sending out valuable
information that's relevant to your
market and
that's not
niche or target market specific and you
assume that everyone is interested in
the message because they joined your
list and everybody that joins your list
it has an interest in your mainstream
market it's just that your target market
is
is that
or your target audience is the specific
audience that you're targeting your
child your market is is a smaller market
outside of that market that you
the target market is a smarter smaller
market out of your mainstream market and
your target audience is
a specific group of people that you're
targeting
and your targeted emails are often more
effective than
bash and blast emails
um that actually is
six and one and a half dozen on the
other targeted emails are good when you
have
a
specific message that you're ascending
to a specific target market
but when you are sending out your blog
post to your list
you can do a batch
and blast does that make sense i hope so
if it doesn't make sense leave me a
message and
i will i will answer your question you
can leave me a message by leaving a
notation in the comments you might need
to give me maybe 24 to 48 hours to get
back to you but definitely it will be
clarified
opt-in opt-out and unsubscribe what does
that mean
opt-in means that somebody
is enters their information to this
to receive your lead magnet and they
start to get your emails okay
opt-out means that
your their consent is implied with the
initial transaction and it's
an action required to opt out in the
future so they people no longer want to
receive communication with you they opt
out or unsubscribe which means that the
recipient is able to remove their name
from your mailing list
spam you heard me use this word spam no
spam no no no no no no spam spam mails
are unsolicited unsolicited and they're
unsubscribed
it means that people have gained access
to your information
through
another through a vendor and they're
sending you um
messages about their product
and
that is not cool don't do that
and show you about my best practices and
spam laws for your email not to be
considered spam
as transactional email is something such
as a purchased product requested
information or downloaded information
blacklist a blacklist is an untrusted
email sender or identified spam source
do not become one of those people okay
learn how to use email effectively
because again you get 400
roi
okay
for 400
email is the largest return of
investment
strategy that you can use digital
digitally
let me say that again
email marketing yields the highest
return on investment in the digital
marketing field
blacklist limits the ability of
organizations or mail sources to send
unsolicited email
don't get caught on this blacklist do
not become one of those people
your open rates
when you send an email
you
well let me backtrack
everything you do
you have to have measure matrices
measures you have to measure your
interactions know what your goals are
your first goal with the email
you want somebody to read that headline
like i need to open that and that is
considered your open rate your open rate
report of how many people open your
email and it is
an unreliable metric
i care to differ but
i care to different because
if people don't open your email
they're not going to read the content in
your email
and if people don't open your email
they're not open their email because
they're not interested in your email
so
if they're not interested that means you
have to figure out why and now sometimes
i determine they're not interested
because your headline sucks and i don't
want to read it so you have to have a
compelling headline
so
it's
good it's a good make sure
to know when people open it because
they're not opening not so out of ten
because it's not engaging it's not
informative they're not interested
email clients report opens differently
use open rate metrics as a guide rather
than a measure of success again yes
that's what i said
you want to see
how many people are opening it because
if you're sending out 100 emails and
only two are opening your emails you
need to figure out what the problem is
you have to be able to diagnose it
at click through is a measurement of how
people interact with your email
and
however it helps to know how many people
taking action to click through through
your email
this is what this is the second thing
that you want to
measure
because the point of the email is to get
people to click the link and to engage
learn information once and they want to
buy your product you want to build that
knowledge trust factor so if they're not
clicking your ink links and reading your
information you're not they're not
interested in you
they're not interacting with you
and that's not what you don't want you
want people to interact when people be
interested
okay
that's what you want you have to measure
that
email client is a computer program used
to read and manage emails
free mail is a free rep based program on
manage
email
your email clients
you have the email client free mail and
web base an email client is a computer
program used to read and manage emails
such as um
outlook
so an email client there are three email
clients you have an email client free
mail and web-based mail an email client
is a computer program used to read and
manage emails such as what i have right
here with outlook okay
this is my email client
a free mail is a free web-based program
to manage email also called webmail
which you use to like gmail yahoo or
hotmail and web-based email
clients act differently from native and
email clients
you